Okay, Katie, you did a fantastic job telling people about feature rescaling.
And now when I put your knowledge to a test,
to see which algorithm you believe is susceptible and
impacted by rescaling features, and which ones are somewhat not impacted.
So here is a set of algorithms.
So which algorithm would be affected by feature rescaling?
Here's a set of algorithms.
That you know very well.
Decision trees, support vector machines, say with a RBF kernel.
You might remember linear regression.
And I'm going to toss in k-means clustering.
It's a pretty non-trivial question.
Some of those will give you the same result even if you rescale the features,
and some of them will have substantially different results.
So check the ones that would be effected.
Where the results really depend on the feature rescaling.